we're talking about drink you're
concerned about great i'm gonna tell you
what i'm concerned about making to the
giant without making a bathroom mistake
my left eyeball is fake sperm my
testicles do not make i woke up this
morning in my booty hole late straight
drake break
crazy
great
[Music]
crazy
go to sea old boy how's kenya
i love kenya i absolutely adore the
place you know
it's so important to protect them you
know oh yes the few untouched tribes
left indeed yes and while we're on the
subject i've got something of a
confession to make oh dear while i was
down there i caught the attention of a
young maasai woman you didn't she took
me for an exotic sophisticated superman
of sorts and developed something of a
liking to me well isn't that always the
way
yes it is and it was quite awful gerald
she came down to my heart wearing
nothing but a fertility headdress and
carrying a husband stick and oh i had to
participate in the custom well you'd be
morally irresponsible if you did not
participate in the custom you could
destroy the entire social structure oh i
felt so terrible about what you did
i felt terrible seven times
but you know gerald i too have a
confession detail remember several years
ago when i went to the amazon yeah yes
well i accidentally packed a lighter in
my satchel oh my yes well one day i
absent-mindedly lit the flint and the
entire village took me for a god
yes every sundown as i was being related
by all the young women of the village
which is the local custom i felt
completely embarrassed by the entire
i can only imagine in some vivid detail
but you can't deny the local customers
you absolutely cannot deny the local
customers
you can hold the local customs one thing
you must do is adhere to the local
costumes
it all reminds me of the time i was in
papua new guinea and i introduced the
local tribe to the french term menage a
trois after that evening a couple of the
local men called me papua oh dear whoops
a daisy
whoopsie daisy indeed it's getting
harder and harder to protect the local
tribes from the influence of the outside
civilization i know exactly what you
mean
exactly and i must confess that the last
time i was deep in the bush in australia
yes i ended up deep in bush in australia
well where are you off to now oh boy
come off to tanzania
make sure that you go during an eclipse
because then everyone will want to have
sex with you
regrettably
oh yeah hey we hitting it and britney
right now right
[Applause]
we out here straight hitting the bricks
as it were hey i'm gonna tell you right
now i got a pocket full of nickels and
i'm ready to get loose all right
okay
get another round
over here yeah oh in the groove
you guys like drake
drink a drink
we got
drake
like drake the rapper he's a musician
like starter from the bottom now we're
here drake
great you can't drink you know a
musician called drink okay you know n
never mind um you guys are awesome
great awesome you know what you're
talking about great job you guys are
awesome nobody knows drink i don't know
nothing about no drake i'll tell you
nothing
i'm trying to watch my calorie intake
worried about no drink concern about
digesting my steak
talking about drinking i'm talking about
drake well i'm having a hard enough time
staying awake i can't be concerning
myself with drake you know poured orange
juice on my cornflakes
he talking about grape trying to talk
about grape i'm trying i need five
breaths to blow out my birthday cake
i ain't concerned about nobody you want
me concerned about drake that's on your
time brother [ __ ] man lost my teeth in
the lake i'm over here like a 1930
cartoon hitting my head when i step on
the ring
no no no no drake you know you're
talking about drake he's concerned about
great i'm gonna tell you what i'm
concerned about making to the jump
without making a bathroom mistake my
left eyeball is fake sperm my testicles
do not make i woke up this morning in my
booty hole late straight drake break
great hey come on no drink
[Music]
oh no look at it
look at these two old timers over here
now jiggly on them walter
i will know because i will
hey
hello gentlemen
y'all like great
drake
hell yes
started from the bottom now the whole
team here y'all like tyler the creator
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
what did moving out
please this is the worst possible time
please don't do this
babe
garbage huh
can i take your garbage yeah sure
you know
i find
the more garbage in the can
the better it feels to dump it all out
i suppose that's why we let it get so
full in the first place
so we can start over
here to fix the cop here
yeah sure sure
hey how did you sometimes things
ain't really broken
it's the way we treat them it needs to
be fixed
[Music]
who the hell are you guys the important
question is
who are you steve
well
if it isn't mr stanley
carl
you need to find your own troubled white
boy
[Music]
[Applause]
i was here first
[Music]
the copycats
sweep this
[Music]
oh
damn
trust the field
there can be only one
magical
[Music]
good lord
are you all right
well
i guess sometimes things have to come
apart before we can put them back
together again oh
you're a magical negro too
who you call a negro [ __ ]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
happy sunday esther happy sunday
georgina
how was your week oh the lord is with me
but the devil he got his hands on my
grandniece grace oh no mm-hmm they're
smoking the reefer and doing the
hanky-panky with boys no dog team or
esther you know
that i love all things that are good and
holy
but if he doesn't let go of my
grandniece grace
i'm gonna cut the devil's dick off and
shove it in his ass
[Music]
with my prayers i know you will joe gina
i know you will
how was your week girl oh you know me
i'm blessed and thankful for everything
all right but you know my grandson jason
got himself wrapped up in the leathery
claws of satan
not jesus he got himself arrested for
the spray painting and the vandalism oh
lord and i tell you i never
raised my hand in anger but if he don't
let jason go i'm gonna punch that [ __ ]
satan in the nuts so hard and wipe the
dick licking smirk off his horned ass
face
with my prayers amen i know you will
esther i know you will but esther i
gotta tear you something nice now oh let
it out you know esther that i have found
serenity in the glory of heaven yes
but my daughter's husband bernard has
got himself wedged between the cleft
hooves and lucifer herself
she opened up her laptop computer
and found the pornography of women not
the pornography absolutely the
pornography of women not on a laptop
computer
i am a pacifist under god's request but
if he don't let go of bernard i'm gonna
sneak up on that [ __ ] ass lucifer
right in the midst of his sleep time
and then i'm gonna sit on that
motherfucker's head and i'm gonna spread
my booty cheeks on that pig's face and
i'm gonna just pucker up my stink hole
and just tubes tubes
[Music]
with the prayers with your prayers of
course of course oh
georgina georgina georgina
oh i got nothing but faith and god in
heaven above but i tell you my son's
wife crystal she got herself wrapped up
in the fiery wings of mephistopheles
herself here we go you know she got
caught using profanity with her own
children what at the dinner table oh
lord
martin
oh i have nothing but love for every
creature on this planet but if he don't
let my darling crystal go i'm gonna
flirt with the devil oh oh show him a
little bit of shoulder how you doing he
gonna start looking away i'm gonna start
twerking start twerking he's gonna be
like where he gonna be he's gonna be
drawn in seduce that little [ __ ]
you can wanna leave hi batting my
eyelashes at him then when he least
expects it and i got his trust that's
when i'm gonna ride that [ __ ] i'm gonna
give him the night of his life and now
he ain't never gonna forget don't give
him this way i'm gonna give him that way
and then right when he about to climax
that's when i'm gonna clinch up my [ __ ]
on that motherfucker's red dick and i'm
gonna snap that [ __ ] [ __ ] off with a
divine
kegel well you gotta snap that little
dick
of course with the prayers yeah but
that's right girl yeah you go get him
yes [ __ ] satan [ __ ] him [ __ ] him indeed
[Music]
it is i
satan
[Applause]
oh
i'm
who is this crazy [ __ ] now ah it's me
[ __ ] your wife's nightmare
the [ __ ] i'm on top of you
what's going on this feels good why
would you do this to me oh you'll see
him a second [ __ ]
please please get these crazy [ __ ]
off of me
[Applause]
[Music]
hey uncle ted oh jesus sound content man
oh keith
i got you didn't i yeah you got me man
you got me pretty good oh so what's
going on today oh just the usual young
buck just another day at the laundromat
yeah while people come in they do their
laundry we chatted up about some of the
topics of the day
that's just another day hanging at the
mat
i wonder what's going on in the
barbershop today
so it looks like they're having fun over
there
[Music]
forget all that keith
come on we got our own assortment of
colorful characters right here in the
map
come on
hey man you need any more corners nope
[Music]
okay
okay
oh hey there miss demetrius you need
some more quarters
[Music]
oh she didn't hear me that's part of the
problem uncle ted
you know all that noise up in here from
the machines running and it's kind of
hot
[Music]
loud and hot
sounds like my old lady
[Music]
billy d williams is in there now he's
lando calrissian he runs cloud city
[Music]
dammit keith
when i tell you we got it going on right
here at the mat baby
uncle ted i got to tell you something
i got my own washer and dryer months ago
i just keep hanging out here cause i
didn't want you to feel bad
oh you didn't want me to feel bad
got your washer dryer all right
oh you're big-timing me now okay i see
how it is hey well your shirt ain't
clean your pants ain't clean
you can't get a good wash on one of them
home watch the drive chat
i'm i'm going
i don't know wait wait wait wait wait
wait
let's have some fun let's have some fun
we would you could get in one of the
laundry cars and i could push it around
no
[Music]
i'm out of here
wait
down that and keep keep
if that don't work then you do a little
tap dance and then you go
i'm your man
hey welcome to the barber shop young man
you're billy g williams yeah yeah how
are you doing i'm good thank you so much
do me a favor yeah could you let go of
my hand
oh thanks man all right
[Music]
um hi
uh are you earl peel
who the hell want to know
i think i'm your son
jordan peel
oh okay i see
come on in here for a minute
close the door on the way in all right
all right man go ahead have a seat i'm
gonna explain something to you okay
i had your dad
all right i'm sorry to disappoint you
but that's the situation brother
are you
you see what's happening
we're doing the same thing
i i always do this i always scratch the
back of my neck like this whenever i'm
in an uncomfortable situation
scratch my neck man everybody scratch
their neck i breathe in and out too man
uh now everybody my kid okay look at
this
that's a picture of me when i was a baby
that's my father
that ain't me
look look look man look at that dude's
afro look i got this going on man my
hair was gray he got black hair i mean
he handsome as hell but i ain't nobody's
daddy
i'm sorry
i just been looking for him everywhere
yeah yeah sure you here it's just i got
my own tv show now
i don't know i just i know that wherever
he is he he would be proud
you got your own tv show huh yeah yeah
yeah i'm
producing and acting um oh you oh you
producing and acting right okay yeah
that's that's my boy
look at that man we're doing the same
thing what is that
holy sh
that's jeans right there man you because
you can't do that unless you're sharing
mad genes with somebody it's got to be
in your dnas
oh
you're my son
my baby boy thanks for your time you
come back oh man i missed you so much
now man stop get off
get off get up
hey
when i first came to your door you
wouldn't even ignore
okay okay you know what when i first
came in here
stop that
when i first came in here you wouldn't
even acknowledge that i could possibly
be your son but now
only after i tell you that i have my own
show on comedy central whoa whoa whoa
whoa comedy central
get the [ __ ] out of my
[Music]
but house know
[Music]